Puede que no nos guste, pero no se puede decir
que la corrupción en Argentina - como en
la inmensa mayor parte de los países - sea
algo precisamente nuevo.
Lo cierto es que desde la primera junta de
gobierno, allá por 1810, prácticamente ningún
gobierno argentino ha estado libre de sospecha.
Y es que, claro… las posibilidades son casi
infinitas… y los incentivos muy generosos.
[Y no, no pensáis que simplemente es meter
la mano y ya, la mayoría de los casos de
corrupción son mucho más enrevesados.]
Sin embargo, amigos, lo que se ha destapado
en los últimos tiempos, especialmente con
el caso de los “cuadernos”, va mucho más
allá.
Estamos hablando de la constatación de que
en La Argentina ha existido un proceso sistemático,
liderado por el propio gobierno de la nación,
con el objetivo de saquear, a gran escala,
las arcas públicas del país.
(Y, ojo, porque… no estamos hablando de...
alguna que otra comisión…. Sino de miles
y miles de millones de dólares que todo apunta
a que fueron robados durante los gobiernos
peronistas de Néstor Kirchner y Cristina
Fernández de Kirchner.
Las novedades se suceden prácticamente a
diario, pero nuestro objetivo con este vídeo
es contaros cómo comenzó, en qué consistía
y cómo funcionaba una trama en la que está
implicada la mismísima Presidencia de la
República… así como decenas de políticos,
jueces, funcionarios y muchos de los más
importantes empresarios del país.)
Amigos, la trama de los “cuadernos” comenzó
con la llegada a la Presidencia de Argentina
de Néstor Kirchner en mayo de 2003 y continuó
bajo la presidencia de su esposa, Cristina
Fernández de Kirchner hasta el año 2015.
Es decir, más de una década de saqueo sistemático
de las arcas públicas.
Ahora bien, antes de ver en qué consistía
y cuánta plata le ha supuesto a los argentinos,
tenemos algunas preguntas que contestar sobre
los auténticos protagonistas de esta historia:
los Kirchner.
¿Quiénes son? ¿Cómo se hicieron con el
poder? ¿Cómo lograron poner en marcha la
que tal vez sea la mayor operación de expolio de toda
la historia
de La Argentina? Atentos.
(EL ASCENSO DE LOS KIRCHNER)
Dos políticos de provincias que lograron
convertirse durante años en los dueños de
la Argentina.
Amigos, todo esto comenzó ni más ni menos
que con una bonita historia de amor entre
dos jóvenes universitarios.
(Néstor y Cristina se conocieron y a mediados
de los años 70 mientras estudiaban derecho
en la Universidad Nacional de la Plata en
Buenos Aires.
El amor surgió muy pronto y en 1976, tras
el golpe militar liderado por el teniente
general Jorge Rafael Videla, nuestros dos
enamorados decidieron marcharse a ejercer
como abogados a la ciudad de Río Gallegos,
en la provincia de Santa Cruz.
Una ciudad que por cierto está lejísimos
de la capital, ni más ni menos que a 2.650km)
[Vamos que si nos hubieran preguntado en aquella
época por el futuro político de esta pareja,
probablemente, la política nacional no habría
sido una respuesta.]
Sin embargo… tras el regreso de la democracia
en 1983, esta bonita pareja de abogados comenzó
a militar en el Partido Peronista… y ahí
fue , amigos, cuando verdaderamente se puso
en marcha la carrera de quienes llegaron a
ser los Underwood de Argentina…
[Bueno, ahora que lo pienso … creo que fueron
los Underwood quienes llegaron a ser los Kirchner
de las series de política. Una relación
por y para el poder.]
Primero, en 1987 Néstor Kirchner fue elegido
intendente de Río Gallegos, alcalde, unos
años más tarde, en 1991, Gobernador de la
Provincia de Santa Cruz y finalmente, en 2003,
Presidente de la República de Argentina.
(Por su parte Cristina Fernández, durante
este tiempo, no se quedó al margen. Hizo
carrera en los cámaras legislativas, diputada
provincial, diputada nacional y senadora nacional…
hasta llegar en 2007 a la presidencia de la
República. Y… luego, en 2015 de vuelta
al Senado.)
[Sí, parece que los Kirchner lo tuvieron
muy claro: entre la abogacía y la política….
La política. Más de 30 años viviendo de
los contribuyentes. Eso sí que es una carrera…]
Sin embargo… esperad un momento.
(La provincia de Santa Cruz, que es donde
comenzaron los Kirchner su carrera política
no solo está lejísimos de la capital, que
al fin y al cabo es el centro del poder, sino
que en 2001 su población no llegaba a los
200.000 habitantes… más o menos un 0,5%
de toda la población del país que en aquel
momento era de 36 millones 260 mil personas.)
Entonces… ¿Cómo es posible que dos políticos
de un lugar tan lejano del poder y tan pequeño
pudieran hacerse con el control de todo el
país?
Esta es la pregunta que durante mucho tiempo
se han hecho muchos periodistas y analistas
políticos. Pues bien… ahora estamos empezando
a conocer la respuesta.
Básicamente, el matrimonio fue copando, cooptando
y comprando casi todos los sectores de la
política argentina a golpe de billetera.
Empresarios, sindicalistas, jueces, periodistas,
artistas y líderes de la sociedad civil sucumbieron
ante el poder de la billetera del estado.
Cientos, miles de millones de dólares repartidos
entre los bolsillos de aquellos que apoyaban
y se manifestaban incondicionales de este
peculiar matrimonio.
Un entramado clientelista aceitado, engrasado,
por concesiones, ayudas y subsidios convenientemente
repartidos y que nadie controlaba. Ahora bien….
La pregunta que obligatoriamente tenemos que
hacernos es… ¿Cómo lo financiaban? ¿Cómo
hicieron los Kirchner para mantener semejante
trama clientelar?
Atentos.
(EL PELOTAZO DE LA OBRA PÚBLICA)
Fijaos en lo que decía en el año 2010 Cristina
Fernández de Kirchner:
(“Para nosotros, para esta Administración,
la obra pública no es una contingencia, es
una convicción; un concepto político estructural
que hemos venido desarrollando no solamente
desde 2003, sino desde que nos tocó la responsabilidad
de dirigir los destinos de una comunidad”.
Cristina Fernández de Kirchner.)
Ahora lo sabemos, ahora sabemos por qué era
tan importante para este matrimonio la obra
pública… Y no, lo siento, pero no tiene
nada que ver con los intereses del país.
La obra pública era una de las partes centrales
del entramado político de los Kirchner, primero
en Santa Cruz y luego en toda La Argentina.
Ahora bien… seguro que alguno de vosotros
se está preguntado, pero, Enrique… ¿Cómo
funcionaba el sistema?
Pues… vereis… en el fondo era bastante
sencillo.
El Presidente Kirchner por medio de su Ministro
de Planificación Federal e Inversión Pública,
Julio de Vido - que lo fue durante toda la
etapa de los Kirchner al frente del país
- se reunía periódicamente con las principales
empresas constructoras del país, que a su
vez eran convocadas por el Presidente de la
Cámara de la Construcción, Carlos Wagner.
Pues bien, en estas reuniones se acordaba
qué empresa se llevaría cada licitación
pública…
Es decir se repartían el pastel en los despachos.
(Luego ya… cuando estaba todo decidido se
convocaba el concurso público… pero esto
era algo simplemente cosmético… siempre
resultaba ganadora la empresa que se había
acordado previamente por esta especie de “cartel
de la obra pública”.)
Y ahora viene la clave de todo el proceso…
(Una vez otorgada la obra, las empresas cobraban
la primera cuota del contrato, el pago adelantado
para supuestamente poder empezar las obras…
sin embargo este pago se entregaba íntegramente
a los políticos.)
Un momento… entonces, ¿Dónde estaba el
negocio si estas empresas tenían que devolver
lo que cobraban?
Pues… en el sobrecoste.
Vereis, se calcula que en promedio el sobrecoste
de cada obra rondaba entre el 30 y el 40 por
ciento de la factura total.
De esta manera, si una obra era concedida
por 100 millones, se aprobaban ampliaciones
en el presupuesto hasta un total de aproximadamente
140 millones.
Pero eso no es todo, luego en ocasiones el
gobierno, además, aprobaba cambios y nuevas
ampliaciones en el proyecto… hasta que la
empresa que se había adjudicado la obra por
100 millones terminaba cobrando muchísimo
más… 180, 200, 250, incluso 2,8 veces el
presupuesto inicial, es decir, en este ejemplo
280 millones… y eso que muchas de estas
obras ni siquiera se terminaban.
Tal cual como lo escucháis.
Por supuesto, a cambio de este chollo, las
empresas pagaban en coimas a los políticos,
según los casos, entre el 10 y el 20% del
importe facturado.
[Viendo lo visto, os habéis preguntado ¿Cómo
funciona en vuestro país la obra pública?]
El caso, amigos, es que todo este proceso
funcionó a la perfección durante años…
Pero ahora… ha quedado al descubierto.
(AL DESCUBIERTO)
Amigos, los pequeños detalles cuentan…
Cuando no se cuidan todos los detalles hasta
las complejas e ingeniosas operaciones corren
el riesgo de venirse abajo. Este caso no ha
sido una excepción.
(Vereis, resulta que el chofer que transportaba
“al recaudador” del gobierno a buscar
las coimas, los maletines, tenía la obsesión
de anotar cada viaje, cada parada, cada edificio
visitado, el nombre de las personas que iban
a ver para la entrega de los maletines…
incluso las conversaciones que escuchaba durante
sus viajes. Todo, practicante todo lo tenía
anotado en 8 cuadernos.)
No se sabe si lo hacía por impulso, por entretenerse,
si formaba parte de una especie de sistema
de control y contabilidad o simplemente quería
cubrirse las espaldas… pero en esos cuadernos
están apuntados todos los detalles de esta
trama mafiosa.
(Y finalmente esos cuadernos… llegaron a
manos de un periodista que al ver lo que contenían
decidió entregarlos a la justicia… y tras
un trabajo de meses de investigación, a finales
de julio de 2018, comenzaron las detenciones
de altos funcionarios y empresarios vinculados
con la trama.)
Pero eso no es todo… ahora muchas de estas
personas han decidido colaborar con la justicia
a cambio de beneficios penitenciarios… como
por ejemplo continuar en libertad y no en
la cárcel mientras continúa el proceso.
Y uno de ellos ha sido precisamente, Carlos
Wagner, el Presidente de la Cámara de la
Construcción, la persona que convocaba a
las empresas y uno de los que más se benefició
de la trama. Su relato confirmó todo lo que
decían los cuadernos.
Y el resto de testimonios van en la misma
línea.
Pero… ahora bien… seguro que os estáis
preguntando, vale, vale, Enrique… pero de
cuánto dinero estamos hablando… pues amigos
de mucho pero que mucho dinero.
Si Carlos Wagner dice la verdad…. Los Kirchner
habrían recibido casi 3 millones de dólares….
3 millones de dólares diarios durante sus
12 años y medio en el gobierno.
En total más de 12.000 millones de dólares
tan solo con las obras públicas. [Porque,
además, sospechas de corrupción y casos
pendientes hay muchos más]
(12.000 millones para pagar a políticos,
jueces, periodistas, líderes sociales…
y, por supuesto también, para llenarse el
bolsillo. Todo apunta a que así es como los
Kirchner se hicieron y consolidaron su poder
sobre La Argentina.)
Ahí tenemos el caso, por ejemplo, de José
López, ex secretario de obras públicas y
muy cercano a Julio de Vido, el ministro kirchnerista
que gestionaba la trama.
Pues bien, en junio de 2016, alertado de que
la policía podría allanar su vivienda en
el marco de una investigación…decidió
salir de su casa a las 3 de la mañana con
9 millones de dólares que tenía en efectivo…
debajo del colchón.
[Oye¿qué se sentirá al tener 9
millones de dólares en efectivo, ahí en
tu casa? Desde luego dinero para pagar al
repartidor de pizzas no le faltaba]
Pues bien, el caso es que esa madrugada trató
de esconder el dinero en un convento, en el
convento de las Monjas Orantes y Penitentes
de Nuestra Señora del Rosario de Fátima
- con tan mala suerte que mientras estaba
metiendo el dinero un vecino que pensó que
se trataba de un robo, llamó a la policía.
Y así es como el bueno de José López fue
pillado infraganti.
Ahora ya sabemos de donde procedía probablemente
todo ese dinero.
Por cierto, otra anécdota, como os podéis
imaginar, este dinero no se podía ingresar
en el banco con una simple transferencia…
No, había que pagarlo en efectivo, en dólares,
por eso de no dejar rastro... así que se
trasladaba en bolsos.
Pues bien, como los pagos eran tan regulares…
los encargados de llenar los bolsos sabían
ya perfectamente cuántos paquetes de dinero
entraban en cada bolso … Así que parece
que el dinero se contaba no ya en millones
sin no directamente en número de bolsos.
Por cierto,no os olvides que las empresas
también ganaban con los sobreprecios… así
que el daño para los argentinos ha sido muchísimo
mayor…
En fin, amigos, esta es la truculenta historia
de como unos políticos deciden saquear su
país. De confirmarse los hechos, quedaría
claro que aquí hasta los Underwood
se escandalizarían.
¿Terminará Cristina Fernández de Kirchner
en la cárcel? Sólo el tiempo nos lo podrá
decir.
De momento como senadora goza de inmunidad,
pero es muy posible que próximamente la Cámara
del Senado decida quitarle sus fueros y la
expresidenta todopoderosa pueda ser juzgada.
Amigos, Si os ha resultado interesante este
vídeo no olvides darle a like.
Por cierto, si quieres conocer más sobre
el peronismo no te pierdes nuestros los dos
vídeos que hemos hecho sobre este movimiento
político. Este es el primero.
Y antes de terminar, muchas gracias a nuestro
amigo Alejandro Gómez por ayudarnos a preparar
este vídeo.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.